so standing around is a crime in
Somerset
brat which one could he possibly be
seeking a sip of fine Russia failed read
prepare for disappointment
the cat like those monsters I'm getting
out of here
ra's enjoys a good fight as much as the
next guy but these are horrible
creatures five claw good to see you
Roz has a proposal if you have the time
have you ever seen such creatures Roz
has not probably neither have you you
are a newcomer yes new to this island of
High Elves this one has an eye for such
things
Dominus know nothing of the sort
well maybe I'll ask some questions
determine the mood in shimmering and see
how the newcomers are fare shimmering
serves as the arrival point for
newcomers to the island
shimmering serves as the arrival point
for new as a matter of fact Roz made a
list all new well a high of artisan
spoke out see what she complained about
all new al complained about it
no no Roz doesn't want to prejudice your
investigation you will find out when you
talk to her
shimmering serves as the arrival bras
nevers as a matter of fact Russ made a
list all new will on Newell true the
divine prosecution something to do with
monks and Newcombe true the divine
prosecution nothing at all Roz never as
a matter of fact something to do with
nothing at all
we need to can well you asked questions
around this
go find your own patch of beach not that
you'd understand the concept but the
path to a lacks on requires debt an
ultimate concept practiced widely here
in samisen I believe in caution as much
as the next hire but sometimes the rules
get in the way of they took her away
said they had to scrutinize her
qualifications they told me I could fill
out some forms and appeal to the Kinley
perfection requires constant vigilance
so back to it
bara caravel how can a humble merchant
help so expire did it just to see her
send you to harass me I've learned after
I filled out all the proper forms and
arranged to bring my cousin here the
ship arrived and they owe my family has
been here for generations and
generations before the Queen's decree
this is unheard of why have you closed
the monastery such anger Rosneft to hear
such words from the Queen's loyal
subject sequestered just a different
word for imprisoned yes Ramos cousin
just arrived but onua wide with the
others gather up newcomers and non hiya
president alike and send him to the
monastery Roz admires your enthusiasm
but this one needs you to enter the
monastery on your own
you then I have it dammit why won't this
work did you see a golden night I have
no idea what that was and I'm not sure I
want to know
sentry trois owes you for that game of
cards and has come to pay
you
no not now please
dose you'll have to ask one of the monks
that the new all dog brought with him
they deal with all the newcomer testing
and evaluations I'm just a simple monk
trying to catch up on my sleep that was
a hint by the way again with the
questions about the new comers white owl
dark till color the all dog and his
month know you'll have to ask all the
old the monastery
I hate trespassers
unusual knick-knack for an all darks
office wouldn't you agree
I noticed you skulking around while I
was engaged in some skulking of my own
the sequestered newcomers I came to find
out what happened to a friend I assume
that's what brought you here as well
interesting I've never seen anything
quite like it I find it in the century
doesn't appear to have stopped you so I
could ask you the same question
that's the question my cautious friend
we have a newly appointed all doc and a
disgruntled kin lady both opposed a
curious pearl I wonder where the old Ark
acquired it probably not important I'll
meet you in the undercroft and we can
see what's going on with the newcomers
are you lost
you can't be in here
something's wrong down here
I sense magic vile magic cages these
people did nothing to deserve such
treatment
there's someone alive over there see if
you can help
thank you behind it's a nightmare we
came to Somerset to see the monks gather
them a few moments ago and is that
scarfing thank you for setting me free
a Daedra here and that's asked often if
I remember my dad Rick recitations
correctly an excellent question and one
I hope to find the answer to from the
evidence before us it appears this Nord
killed the scuffing before he succumbed
then I suggest we pick up the pace I'll
explain everything later for now we need
to hurry
Daedric cultists
the pearls draining these people
more newcomers unfortunately the magic
only affects those who have been
prepared but never fear your turn will
come
I'll deal with the pearl you hold off
these creatures magic attracts these
creatures hold them off while I complete
my spell
come on let's talk outside
those poor people this wasn't just about
newcomers and opposing I promise to
explain what I know
I suppose that now's as good a time as
any
I'm a member of the Civic order our
right master sent me to investigate a
warning we received the city
order is an ancient magical monastic
Society we served as advisors to the
rulers of Tamriel but that was an eye of
the Queen interesting I diffused the
Daedric magic and transported the Pearl
to Artyom
you
you
living on Artyom for a few centuries
doesn't prepare you for physical
activity let the eye of the Queen know
what we discovered and I'll catch up
with you later
ah this one's new partner returns what
interesting that isn't the kind of
scandal Roz was hoping for murder they
accuse not exactly Rossi Jake Rogers
there was a life sucking power in keenly
the avenues and rod
yes and who might you be the Kin lady is
currently engaged she's holding a
conference hmm yes
so you do
we all have concerns regarding the
Queens to creep I assure you that I am
working with old arctic allah to
safeguard the sanctity of shimmering and
all of somerset enjoy the food and drink
business of the city requires my
attention but i shall rejoin you shortly
I see the Queen's decree your had you
really I suddenly remembered some
business I need to deal with as well
feel free to BES to the other guests in
my absence to my home without so much as
a by-your-leave
I'm sorry Karen but I have no time for
such innocence you really want to know
why I oppose the Queen's order to allow
newcomers to enter Somerset all dr.
Carla came highly recommended
he has grand plans for protecting ship
not that it's any concern of yours
that's preposterous all dr. Carla
sequest is the newcomer milady one of
the monks had to deliver this message
it's from the old doc himself the coral
forest an art location for a meeting but
I need to hear the old dogs explanation
pretend you are adjusting your boot or
admiring the onion rush things have an
easy the coral forest I'm glad I found
you while watching the King ladies
mansion I saw her ladyship sneak out the
back and leave the city the king lady is
meeting the all dark in the coral forest
rah smells something and it isn't moon
sugar biscuits your reputation precedes
you I've the queen I am vowing of the
siddik Order and I agree that the all
dark is more than a simple monk we
should work together yes but let's
travel separately to avoid attracting
unwanted attention Roz will find you
both at the coral forest
one of Somerset's more unique
environments based on what we saw on the
monasteries undercroft i'm hesitant to
use magic to locate them you know
nothing of the plan you fool let me give
you a taste of what the prince of
bargains has in store for this pitiful
world
come never our let me show you the power
bestowed upon me by the prince of
bargains let me show you the power
bestowed upon me by the gara destroy
these fools
resumed our apprehended the Kin lady
there at the west edge of the coral
forest I think we can conclude that till
Carlin wasn't actually in or dock at
least not with his connection to the
prince of bargains Club you'd be
surprised what a particular object the
right mass deletes the siddik order from
Kippur atop one more adjustment and
there you are now attuned find me on
Artyom after you finish with the eye of
the Queen
ah five claw my social standing is
brilliant Roz had the most ill look
Queen Iran will be disappointed that the
King lady of the prince of this city
then you must have you come to gloat to
kick me while I met him at King Lord
melon thales party in Elinor we had
similar ideas about the Queen's decree
and I recommended that he lead the
monastery Somerset isn't a stewpot and
the various what a hateful accusation
till color told me he was going to send
them back with it I certainly hope not
we'll have to get the divine prosecutor
mind your step there stranger these
little beauty
you
you
I happen to be the only merchant on
and there was no sign of Lathan I don't
know whether to be grateful or concerned
we'll find him Val now go check on the
pearl while I speak to art what a rare
honor valor and bestowed upon you only a
select few not of our order have ever
walked upon this sacred island
unfortunate certainly the magic you
described sounds familiar
so the seal what a little indeed but not
until we finish studying the pearl Val
sir and brought us there are mysteries
to unravel and Val believes you will be
the next step involves the thorough
examination of the strange pearl you and
me